since the start of the full-scale war
the Ukrainian ports in the black and as
of seas have been blocked by Russia
until now our ports on the Danube River
Remain the target for missiles and
drones
and it is a clear Russia's attempt to
weaponize the food shortage on the
global market in exchange for
recognition for some if not all of the
captured territories
Russia is launching the food prices as
weapons
the impact spans from the Atlantic coast
of Africa to the southeast Asia and this
is the threat scale we know the names of
tens of thousands of children
and have evidence on hundreds of
thousands of others kidnapped by Russia
in the occupied territories of Ukraine
and let deported
the international
Criminal Court
issued a rest warrant for Putin
for this crime
and we are trying to get children back
home
but time time goes by what will happen
with them what will happen to them
those children in Russia are taught to
hate Ukraine and all ties with their
families are broken and this is clearly
a genocide
Russia is weaponizing nuclear energy not
only it is not only it is spreading its
unreliable nuclear power plant
Construction Technologies but it is also
turning other countries power plants
into real dirty bombs
did to our the Parisian power plant
celled occupied it and now blackmails
others with radiation leaks
is there any sense to reduce nuclear
weapons when Russia is weaponizing
nuclear power plants
scary question
while Russia is pushing the world to the
final war Ukraine is doing everything to
ensure that after Russian aggression no
one in the world will dare to attack Any
Nation we organization must be
restrained war crimes must be punished
deported people must come back home and
the occupier must return to their own
land we must be United to make it and
we'll do it slavocrine
foreign
[Applause]